sta crepando tutti ragazzi pervenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
tornati su the forest che tipo non so
quante vite ho passato prima a prossima
se magari registro potrebbe essere una
soluzione vero ecco adesso il partito
scusate conosciamo ma questo già lo
sapete siamo altro gratis to the four e
era è un secolo che non veramente non mi
corno manco più come si parte alla lotta
hanno aggiornato talmente tanto sto
gioco che non mi ricordo assolutamente
più cosa cosa c'era prima
che bello vedo che hanno aggiunto la
sbobba fantastico a noi sbagliamo
cliccato il tasto per saltare su sorry
addirittura al sangue nei videogiochi
wow nuova generazione grandissimo ho
saltato l'intero ragazzi sono un
deficiente scusatemi leggere l'aereo che
cadeva quell'albero mi fa paura c'è il
stai calmo zio avevo calmo nella vita
devi stare sto provando a fare una roba
seria voglio portarlo avanti sto gioco
perché non l'ho mai giocato seriamente
seriamente c'è il genero sempre
cazzeggiato vero zia tipo adesso ho
provato a staccarlo in braccio ma non
riesco a mangiarlo quindi va bene non
sono ancora un gol va a van walle non
c'è nessuno prefetto in realtà ragazzi
mi è capitato spesso di uscire
dall'aereo e trovarmi gente davanti
quindi evitiamo giorno mirino vieni
mieli sono tuo amico vieni beccato è
oscar madonna se sei più lento di mia
nonna in calore per lo zio cioè datte na
calmata piano sono fa vj ho trovato la
madonna prende sky sta roba
va bene comunque ci sono teschi cosa non
c'è un che cos'è è uno spazzolino
ma come c'è uno spazzolino impiantato
nel teschio bellissima sta cosa ciao
ciao bambina già bocciato l'anima de li
mortacci tua ma che cazzo di passi
attraverso gli alberi
vieni qua siano no non ti voglio fare
niente carica si gioca non ci credo non
è vero non è vero ho mancato ragazzi è
uno scherzo lurida bambi di merda vieni
qua non si posso credere mai ma che ho
fatto manca era un metro da zia sul
serio non si suicida è lo sapevo in
sicilia
ma no povera banche ma forza ma sul
serio
io volevo solo un'amica bambine america
brutta bastarda di merda vieni qua corri
brava concordi thrones cori che
rimangono sette pio a sentire è un gioco
di sopravvivenza o in gioco dove
dobbiamo rincorrere le lepri stajan ma
niente mamma mia
mango ci avesse al ciclo allo ragazzi
cerchiamo nuove serie invece di
inseguire bambi e basta allora siccome
voglio giocarlo seriamente sto gioco
cerco di trovare cose per sopravvivere
tipo nelle valigie eccole le valigie
milan non ne trovo manco una quando
voglio giocare seriamente non trovo
manca una valigia fantastico ho trovato
un foulard
speriamo che sia di chanel perché non
vado in giro con queste cose non di
marca che ha la valigia rosa nomadi melo
c'è voglio capire anche una donna povera
valigie illegale
ho tagliato dei rami senza volerlo vabbè
ce ne andiamo comunque la valigia non la
posso portare ma se con noi perché la
valigia si porta e la porta non si
valigia
la prossima volta che dico una stronzata
del genere mi suicido tipo bambino con
il cazzo sei tu sei stato dove stavo
inseguendo un coniglio è sparito nel
nulla fantastico vabbè
eccolo dai stronzo perché non riesco a
prendere niente oggi e va a fan culo da
zio michè un'ora un'ora e mezza per
trovare la facevo prima andare in
macelleria e tornare maledizione questo
è l'ultimo giuro bastano ne prendo più
bassa mi sono rotto le palle di cercare
animali facciamo un fuoco decente
appellava donna addirittura in mano come
se fosse proprio un kinder cereali tieni
tieni che titola merenda ma voi ragazzi
siamo a posto con la roba da prendere
cioè non presa da parecchia quindi direi
di fare un focolare
devo solo capire bene dove farlo cosa è
stato storm ore bruttissimo
oddio le anatre veramente hanno aggiunto
le anatre fatemi provare fatemi fatemi
ecco mi ha visto non mi ha visto non mi
ha visto non mi ha visto che botta di
culo increa ok forse non è forse non è
il posto adattissimo per fare
l'accampamento mi riguarda farei
dietrofront e molto volentieri grazie è
stato bello ora cam ignota ma tra tutti
i punti in cui potevo credere ma proprio
vicino al villaggio ma che cazzo di
sfiga io devo trovare un posto
tranquillo per per accamparsi cioè
possiamo fare ragazzi non è difficile
poi inizierò a tirare un pò giù di
alberi vorrei provare a costruire un
sacco di roba che partono quanta roba
hanno aggiunto trova tim.it in me perché
si chiama timi il bambino allora vi
spiego perché ho saltato la intro in
realtà the forest quando parte c'era il
bambino che mi dormiva misbah vada sulla
spalla viene catturato da quegli
indigeni lì e non lo si è mai più visto
io non l'ho mai più visto quando giocato
de force mai adesso nel libro c'è
scritto find timi fare un accampamento e
trovare l'altra parte del
dell'aereo perché l'aereo è spaccato a
metà perfetto tipo tv lost scusami ma
cosa non dall'altra parte del lago ma se
prima ero lì adesso come faccio a essere
qui non è possibile poi cosa cazzo è
successo io li fatto un po di pani
sporchi devono essere almeno gianello
pure trussardi perché sennò non indosso
stronzi
beh con un altro miliardo rilasciate lo
buttiamo giù vabbè però ma quante e
quanti cazzo siete gli stavo restano va
ditemelo
ma quanto all'aumento cazzo pensavo
fossi disabitato non è disabitato manco
per il pene ecco non è esattamente il
perché non posso fare una porca e odio
perché ci sono dei tronchi preferivo dei
kinder bueno non fa ridere non fa ridere
avevo detto che mi sarei suicidato se
avessi letto un'altra battuta del genere
d'accordo ragazzi siamo arrivati in uno
spara giorno bene volevo a camp armi qui
però mi sa che mi sa di no io vorrei
capire una roba siccome questo qua è una
caverna e nelle caverne ci sono quegli
stronzi lì spiegatemi un attimo come
cazzo possibile che ci sia una corda che
vuol dirmi che i ragazzotti nudi come
hobby fanno e gli scalatori non ditemelo
a ok mi piace lo faccio messo una vita e
mezza per trovare la spiaggia
impossibile che c'è una barca ma questa
è la spiaggia quella solita non lo so è
nuova e tutto il nuovo ragazzi hanno
fatto completamente tutta la mappa erano
di fatto mi metto qui ragazzi perché mi
sembra allora innanzitutto qua non ci
arrivano gli aborigeni devono proprio
buttarsi giù dal precipizio quindi
famose un accampamento qui tranquillo
qua non ci pigliano ma neanche se che
avvengono con il call tomtom cercarci
che per fare questo ottimo mica che
punto della madonna
posso anche nascondermi che figo prima
di tutto ragazzi troviamo così messo di
nuovo ma ci sono quattro tipi di fuochi
e facciamo prima il rifugio normale così
almeno la cabina possiamo farla cabina
per o quell'altro pone a facciamo questo
dai come primo va benissimo
mettiamolo qua
la madonna quanta roba aveva poi
mettiamo già guarda voglio fare già le
basi proprio completamente facciamo
anche la cabina mettiamola qua guarda
che roba potente ciò anche vista mare
fantastico perfetto l'ho già piazzato
già piazzato quasi tutto sta diventando
buio quindi devo muovere il culo prima
che diventi buio sul serio può trovare
20 fogli dove le trovo 20 foglio non
sono anch'io
vabbè cerchiamo per questo trovo e 10
rami eventi foglie dacia posso fare ce
la posso fare vai io trovo solo pietre
non so se è normale
ciao zio sta diventando purissimo e
quegli stronzi escono di notte quindi
devo muovermi prima che mi mi trovo da
confraternita 89 ante buio mi serve una
torcia devo farmi lato ho cercato di
farmi un miliardo di cose o i rametti
sono questi è quindi quelli li ho già
trovati praticamente tutte a ci sia
qualche figo che ti dice quanto manca
fantastico ma posso prenderne tanti a 9
di non mi fa più prendere vaffan cuore
ok allora devo portare questi e poi
tornare che palle farsi rifugio ragazzi
se vedete un uomo nelle foreste nudo
intanto sono nudo io non sono un cie
pantaloni grazie a dio beh se vedete gli
uomini nudi non sono io
salve mi scusi ma mi serviva la cena
grazia che figo come arrivo tattico nel
mio accampamento fantastiche tra l'altro
non vedo veramente niente zero o
perfettissimo [ __ ] mi mancano 10
ma che cazzo ma se occorso di chilometri
come cazzo faccio essere qui ma bastava
che faccio due ma sono due metri buono
buono zio no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no non ascoltami scott e mi
sono vengo in pace quella ero te lo
regalo è te lo regalo guarda che non è
un playmobil un aereo vero te lo regalo
io te lo regala lo zio favi se mi lasci
in pace giuro che non dico nessuno
quanto sei brutta ma era un uomo una
donna s'è visto un cazzo visto solo
qualcuno che si muoveva nell'oscurità
fantastico mi carica ai ragazzi ho
trovato il posto della vita vi giuro
sono contentissimo se non fosse per
l'aereo vicino o mio dio ce l'abbiamo
fatta ragazzi è anche il fuoco ce la
faccio fatti ea dargli fuoco maledizione
che voglio io in questa giornata che non
ne posso più 40 anni per fare un
accampamento ragazzi devo fare anche
questo che però vabbè ci metterà un po
di più visto che se con i tronchi quelli
pesi tanto li butto giù dalla collina
fantasma
si può salvare la partita sì sì
fantastico ragazzi può salvare la
partita che firmi cassa cosa che non
c'era prima e fico sono contentissimo
allo ragazzi abbiamo salvato la porta a
salve e la cena grazie gentile me l'ha
mandata la mia amica questa brutto
bastardo vi qua dai che c'è solo al mare
non puoi scappare è scappato
no no no no no no no ragazzi ragazzi
ragazzi se n'è accorto regalo se n'è
accorto lega porca [ __ ] d'accordo
ragazzi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
concludo più l'episodio so che lì
concludo nel momento sbagliato gli
episodi però io sono fatto così i
ragazzi mi odio anch'io per questo
quando vi riguardo mi odio da solo
fatemi sapere ragazzi se l'episodio è
piaciuto lasciato un commento è un mi
piace è incapace di facebook come vi
adottata descrizione se ne sono resi
discreti mio ci vediamo non possimo
vinto dai ragazzi